ce ne sera pas jean louis borloo parce
que entre boire et conduire un
gouvernement il a déjà choisi ce ne sera
pas gérard larcher qui alors qu'il est
toujours coincé à l'intérieur de
l'isoloir depuis dimanche dernier pour
quelqu'un qui dit qu'il a changé et qui
va plus écoutés il commence mal c'est
pas en repoussant l'âge de la retraite
qu'on va libérer de l'emploi pour tous
les jeunes qui attendre d'en avoir ce
sera une femme mais laquelle vous avez
une idée vous tirez
à pronostics
ségolène royal ce que nous avons proposé
à nos potentiels partenaires ça n'est
pas un accord électoral à la petite
semaine simplement pour se répartir des
postes et faire croire que finalement
tout ce qui nous aurait séparé
précédemment n'existerait plus c'est pas
parce que vous répéter à longueur
d'année que nous sommes anti européen
nous allons quitter l'euro qui est l
europe que c'est vrai oui non mais je
voulais pas nous l'avait dit j'ai dit
les journalistes de palais à vous toutes
seules
choses à leur place c'est bien que vous
allez essayer de ne pas dire que il sait
pas vous cannes beckham et d'autres que
vous que affreux que ça va être
finalement la destruction de l'europe
mais jean-luc mélenchon ça disent les
verts ils sont pris compris hier soir il
dit je reste en l'europe je ne sens pas
de l'euro il se trouve que je connais
beaucoup de responsables de gauche alors
dit et vous où il voulait dans l'oreille
qui ne sont pas d'accord passeront le
reste face à face ou téléphone qui vous
dit qu'ils s'arrangent si si si si moi
je m'adresse
je ne trahit jamais les conversations à
gauche comme avait dit laurent déjà pour
la l'élection présentielle si elle ne
comprend pas qu'elle a une
responsabilité historique devant la
montée de l'extrême droite en france et
bien qu'elles rentrent chez elles et
qu'elles arrêtent parce que il était
d'accord air france entend tout toutes
les réflexions sur un pacte de
gouvernement un rassemblement dans une
majorité
présidentielle ça ça porte un nom c'est
le parti unique le parti unique c'est la
monarchie
vous m'aviez annoncé que j'étais au fond
du trou et responsable du désastre et
c'est ici et vous vous avez ramassé pour
la manière de me parler un avis du
conseil
j'ai très vite dit que vous seriez au
deuxième tour soyons honnêtes parce que
j'ai très vite compris qu'ils auraient
un vote utile à gauche en votre faveur
le pire est à venir avec emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron va gouverner à gauche et
avec l'ultra gauche ceux qui s'apprêtent
à émerger lors des élections
législatives ce talent avoir à la fois
un bloc macro nice tu es un bloc
mélenchonistes
ne dit pas long du nom était un des
premiers à le dire ici le trouble
le veut la tradition au sein du
rassemblement national jordan bardella
président par intérim du parti a déposé
ce matin une gerbe devant la statue de
jeanne d'arc place saint-augustin à
paris notez que marine le pen n'a pas
fait le déplacement dans une brève vidéo
publiée ce matin sur les réseaux sociaux
société qui reconnaît la valeur du
travail ne peut accepter de porter l'âge
de départ à la retraite à 65 ans la
retraite doit permettre à tous ceux qui
ont contribué à la richesse de la france
de profiter d' année de repos et de
bonheur en bonne santé elle n'est pas là
ça ne vous aura pas échappé qu'elle sort
d'une campagne présidentielle qui a été
qui a été éprouvante et qui l'amenait
rassemblé 13 millions de voix donc elle
se prépare dès maintenant à cette
bataille des élections législatives et
comme voici que s'avance devant nous une
élection qui peut nous permettre de
vaincre ceux qui ont l'intention de vous
si ce blocage est une menace réelle
alors ya un moyen très simple pour lever
le blocage c'est de dire ce sont les
français qui choisiront donc le
référendum est donc j'ai toujours
défendu cette idée du référendum je dis
pas que c'est une idée majoritaire elle
ne l'est pas qu'est-ce qui manque là
maintenant
il est temps qu en journalisme
d'investigation
vous arrivez à dire du mal de moi pas
chacune et vos émissions donc faire
enquête